[Applause]
I'm going to take it back to Skylar's
first slide or one of his early slides
so this picture comes up a lot at MIT
servomechanisms lab hooking up the early
whirlwind to a machine to be able to
achieve precision with a computer that
is acting on material so programmable
the panel we're enacting efforts on
material by programming machines then
maybe this is the earliest instantiation
of it 1951 may be a Nicholas was still
known as Nicky or maybe he's about my
age I think be a thing though about this
machine is that this is still how we
create stuff I'm in the center for bits
and atoms and we work together with NASA
in some time and this is their milling
machine they use it to make large
titanium parts that end up on the space
station this is the same milling machine
as is in that picture from Popular
Mechanics in 1950 that one ran on a
vacuum tube machine this one runs
Windows XP it's a not necessarily a
whole lot of change has taken place in
terms of how we're programming machines
that we're using to create different
kinds of material structures and when I
first showed up at MIT I thought that
the way that we were going to make this
more broadly applicable is everything
was going to be smaller cheaper and easy
to take home and use at a personal scale
personal fabrication as you had
industrial fabrication this is a milling
machine that is made on a milling
machine that is four hundred dollars in
parts and you can program it to do
largely the same kind of operations as
the Cincinnati hydro tell however if you
think about the ENIAC for example as a
large mainframe computer that is able to
do any kind of calculation and you think
about your phone you do the same
calculations and you end up with the
same answer your phone might just take a
lot longer or probably by now a lot
faster than the ENIAC computer however
if you take the cincinnati hydrogel and
you take this machine
they're not actually able to make the
same things this smaller machine can
only make smaller things it is less
stiff and therefore can make things that
are less precise and so it's kind of
reimagining of what programming material
is like or what it is like to fabricate
stuff making everything just smaller and
cheaper is not really the direction that
maybe we should be going in if you look
at why this is the case you know as
people develop digital fabrication as we
know it now CAD tools cam tools and
machinists that would execute those
programs those are all different roles
those are all people you know we're
programming programming things but
things do not just program themselves
and your introduction Schuyler you said
that I make machines that make machines
is not true I just make machines that
make stuff Lea and people that program
those machines are who decides what
stuff gets made and when you program a
machine now you enact all of the
different roles of these peoples or
these jobs and careers that have taken
place and are really historically
grounded at the time you needed someone
else who is going to be running a
computer because like Nicholas mentioned
those things were 250,000 dollars and
someone else is running the milling
machine because also similarly expensive
and now all of those things are easier
more accessible and kind of collapsing
and yet the fields that that they embody
remains sort of separate I can program
geometry and Rhyno I can program sensor
networks with LabVIEW and yet if you
wanted to easily flow from one data flow
graph to the next there aren't
necessarily a whole lot of easy
connection points between the two so in
reimagining what maybe digital
fabrication could look like together
with a lot more I thought maybe instead
of mainframes what we need is laptops
you know let's make things portable this
is a this is a hop up digital
fabrication
machine that you can bring around and 3d
printer and a milling machine and a
cutting machine and for some reason I
take it on airplanes
the TSA never asks me questions about it
strange and they ask me questions about
my mouth a lot you know my ass my 3d
mouth but not about this machine and it
fits downstairs downstairs yes
downstairs so if you wanted to come see
it and show you how we made it and what
it does but it doesn't actually make
things that are much more exciting than
this small plastic fish
I can make circuit boards the circuit
boards can run the separate motors of
the machine but it doesn't really extend
outside of the work envelope of this
suitcase and so even though it's
portable it doesn't necessarily work on
its environment you can just take it
with you and it becomes something that
you can do what you otherwise would do
in a large lab with and that was a kind
of frustrating exercise as well to
actually make this all fit into one
briefcase to be able to control both the
3d print head and a milling head you
need different electronics different
electronics and have to be added to this
different board at some point I wanted
it to also pipette so do liquid handling
for bio experiments and then to augment
that board to be able to do other kinds
of control system things was very
frustrating is to redesign the whole
thing and then change things and so we
decided it would be easier if machines
were controlled through networks of
control nodes rather than a single
control unit and historically this has
not been the case because the bandwidth
of communication between nodes on a
network wasn't high enough to be able to
do things like moving around really fast
but now that is no longer the case and
so doing network controls for machines
is really quite feasible and to not stop
there we saw that well why do we
necessarily also have to have this
single work envelope if I want to make
something that's really thin and long
versus something that's really small or
something that's really big why can't I
just change the machine on the fly to
accommodate that and so these are a
reconfigurable modular machine
parts that you then assemble into
machines as opposed to seeing here's the
Star Trek replicator it can do
everything for everyone we're not going
to tell you how it was made because we
don't know either
and so each one of these are nodes
mechanical nodes correspond sort
electrical node which set in software
also corresponds to a virtual machine or
what we have confusingly called a
commercial machine and then there's some
software application that needs to
program it all or the interface and here
is a version of the machine that we
assembled to do film cuttings this is
for access control and very useful to
have for access control if you wanted to
make an object that says hell on one
side or ya on the other or circle on one
side of the square on the other and so
here you can see a network node and a
way that we're actually running this
machine though is still totally separate
where we have a design file which then
creates a tool path which is then being
run on the machine so it's still
enacting the same hierarchy of things
that happen one after another and this
is how it was programmed it creates like
a file it's not necessarily exactly the
same code that's running to Cincinnati
hydrate hell it's not G code but it's
still very very similar and that's maybe
not the way in which workflow
composition should take place if I
wanted to say for example here is a
petri dish when it turns pink please
feed up to this temperature and then
shake it around a bunch how am I going
to specify that in that kind of
programming language they haven't really
kept up and so this is a browser-based
environment for doing workflow
composition for digital fabrication and
also other kinds of processes where
instead of saying okay I'm going to make
one file that is then going to go from
my computer to the computer that is
inevitably attached to these digital
fabrication machines
and run it you can say okay we can
actually now we even have the bandwidth
that we can do closed-loop control from
within what you would otherwise consider
the master computer or the computer that
is trying to generate the instructions
for the machines and so instead of a
kind of classical you have some kind of
file you know you can add a video input
and have your machine respond to the
environment that way or add different
kinds of components and the reason that
we're doing this all in the browser is
because the idea is that this is going
to be something that's not done by
people like me but it's done by people
like kids or people who are trying to
automate something in a different kind
of space and so here you can quickly
create tool paths in your face very
useful and I guess doing all of this we
made different machines for different
applications this was a airfoil that we
made for colleagues in the lab you know
how do you where do you find a six-foot
wide foam cutter the last moment well
you could also just make one or this is
a work that we're doing with Jeff Koons
studio where he constantly needs to
measure all kinds of crazy things and
build all kinds of crazy things and so
if you need to take eight thousand
photographs of a single object it's a
rather tedious task to do by hand so can
you have people working in the studio
automate those things with machines like
this as well but it's not so useful
necessarily for only me to have access
to these tools and and you know the
concept of modularity and machines and
modularity and construction of machines
are not rapid prototyping but rapid
prototyping of rapid prototyping or
rapidly automating things like how do
you lower the threshold from where you
would otherwise say this is something
you need to do by hand - this is
something that you can automate and so
we made a version of this machine kit
out of cardboard
and the idea there is that anyone should
be able to make machine not as a
semester project not as an undergraduate
like in Mecca at MIT but as someone who
is not necessarily familiar with all
engineering but is okay with spending an
afternoon putting together things out of
cardboard and assembling a machine and
doing then another iteration once they
figured out the first automation
workflow so there are the Center for
bits and atoms has sort of a outreach
network slash has facilitated for a long
time with Fab Lab Network and fab labs
take this class called fab Academy which
is a parable of how to make them with
anything at MIT and so they were kind of
the first testers of this kit where can
they make different kinds of machines
using these modular components and so
this is what they did you can see that
you know cardboard is not material where
someone is like oh I don't know how to
drill a hole net or I don't know how to
modify that you just kind of cut it you
add some glue it's no big deal
so they made some whimsical machines
like these coffee stirring machines or a
lightshow machines but you can see also
well originally was considered difficult
5-axis control is not necessarily
considered difficult anymore when
everything is remarkable as you just add
more axes you know you want successes
control you want seven axis control you
know who cares just add more things to
the network so you have traditional like
machines like a lathe or the non
traditional machines like precision
ketchup applications and this kind of
things all kind of whimsical right these
are sort of silly machines maybe but if
you can have whimsy with the precision
of computer control or if you can have
whimsy with automation and imagine the
things that you could do for other
things that require precision vision
agriculture medical applications and and
so this a tool chain or a toolkit idea
of how to build things up as a
automatable I think is a
is really powerful and being being able
to really interplay between different
systems is a is an important component
of designing machines like this and so
in terms of being material maybe I'm
still sort of behind the self-assembly
lab I'm not programming materials I'm
just making it easy to program other
things for the production of things
[Applause]